mit has an educational philosophy of
learning by doing so it's fine to know
about the theoretical equations it's
quite another thing when you actually
have to build something and for a lot of
students this is the first time they've
ever built anything if you take RTD
capstone class it's where you take the
different things you've learned in your
undergraduate education and pull them
into something that integrates them in
our case we do capstone class looking at
the design and construction of an either
airplane or spacecraft there's a lot of
systems I've gotten a lot of recognition
that started with a senior capstone
class so it'd always be awesome to be
the next iteration of that
this innovative solutions the spins come
up with is a challenging problem that's
what's really unique and that's what a
specialist really value you don't really
build much in the first semester and
you're not meant to the idea is for
everyone to come in to work with their
models to come up with ideas and
sketches and then in the spring you take
the old designs and you iterate on them
experimentally and then you build them
and you try to get to the thing apply we
wanted to create unmanned aerial vehicle
along with a submersible system that
will be used to either conduct
reconnaissance or search-and-rescue
missions and blue water operations the
project was sponsored by the Office of
Naval Research and the motivation was to
be able to resupply a UAV in deep water
when you're away from land when I first
heard of it I was like oh this is so
cool one of the major problems with sea
planes is that they can dig their
pontoons in and flip upon landing
students came up with a relatively
ingenious idea of having the pontoons
rotate so that if the airplane did end
up on its back it wouldn't be like a
turtle on its back it would be able to
get flipped over there is a worm gear
system inside the airplane that tilts
the pontoons so it kind of does an
upside-down push up then the body
actually is lifted out of the water and
then the body is then free to rotate
around there's a very strong software
and autonomy component so the pod knows
where it is with its local GPS system so
with broadcast message the airplane I'm
at this location the airplane comes in
lands close to that location they use an
optical camera that was sensitive to
certain colors they put colored markers
on the pod so that the optical system
would know to look for the signature of
the
now that sounds pretty easy but it
actually gets tough because now you're
in rough water so the pot isn't still
it's going up and down the airplanes
being bounced around so it has to find
that target and it has to sort of
average out where the target is going to
be and head in that direction as it gets
closer and closer it gets a better
better fix
while to do submarining at speed and I
don't have enough queue on the tail to
be able to bring the nose up yeah we
couldn't get the airplane takeoff we
tried a couple different angles and flap
settings and go to takeoff diagnosed it
as the pontoons submarining down into
the water did a quick fix for that just
you know mix up some glue and pieces of
plywood to try to get the pontoons to
set up the world better
you take it to the field and you try it
and if it doesn't work you take video
and you take measurements in you use
that to refine your design first flight
test first crash it's worth the way it
goes in this business
it actually gets a fly but we did learn
what we need to be able to fly basically
we hadn't we hadn't done enough surface
area attachment on the inside of the
carbon fiber so the legs actually
sheared and we weren't able to take off
property on the final takeoff attempt
and then before that we realized that
our tail gets a little bit bigger so we
could have more north control authority
and then those are some other
modifications that we made so far and
fly on Wednesday they're figuring out
how things that look good on paper a
theoretical models work in the real
world their understanding that you have
to make approximations you have to use
engineering judgment you have to decide
what's important and what's not
important after the flight test at the
pond
we made it under changes to the aircraft
first of all the biggest change is that
we took the tail which was here and
which was too small gave it a bigger
tail and put it here in the prop wash of
the motors and we included these scoops
at the front of the pontoons to help
with the pitch stability and the
submarining problem on the water and all
these design changes have been carried
over onto the new aircraft which has
these hooks here to allow the water to
separate and for it to build up high
pressure that keeps the pontoons from
nose-diving into the water and this one
has also been given a molded Kevlar
fuselage to improve the aerodynamics and
keep everything inside
what's special about the capstone
process is the fact that it's really
simulating the engineering environment
many of the students describe the
experience of transformation they become
fearless
the fact that they get to experience
being both an engineer and the
technician somebody who actually is the
one who puts these things together I
think makes them better engineers
because they can learn to understand how
their designs could actually be built